[Musik]
hollywood wasser hat vorjahr
murat ernsthaft herzlich willkommen zum
arzt grandiosen 5 minuten
und zwar fünf minuten warum im
durchschnitt länger konzentrieren kommt
genau hast du dich dennoch harheimer wir
machen heute das ganz ganz besonders uns
waren wir machen heute kuchen den gummis
seit jahren schon gemacht hat also alle
leute aus der anstalt haben immer gesagt
der schmeckt gut weniger das machst ja
jedes jahr zum geburtstag und der ab
juli hat das rezept zu einem kopf wieder
ich viel im kopf aber dieses rezept hat
er sich merken können und das ist ein
ganz besonderer coolen gehen dafür
lieben dich die menschen haben mich die
menschen auch so ja das ist gelogen er
liebt auch er ist ein sehr guter lügner
juni der könig ist mein assistent
bis heute werden assistiert und ich
werde zuschauen wie du diesen grandiosen
wien ihm am morgen zusammen
okay es ist alles da wie gesagt die
rezepte ist ganz speziell verging im
kopf wieder zehn mal von den zutaten
also wir brauchen 500 gramm mehl 250
gramm butter oder margarine eine halbe
tasse tasse milch 200 gramm zucker fünf
eier und prise salz und müssten kein
haus ist ja das ganze krise da ist es
halt finden hast du hast aber gerade in
rom us klatschpresse tucker und auch
vorne lag
so machen wir ja kuchen ist ziemlich
richtig einfach merkt er einfach daran
dass die bienen auf machen kann
und jetzt gehen was macht es als erstes
thema war die feier in die schüssel
reichmann gegen erzählen ein bisschen
über die eier das sind bio-eier habe ich
mir den ich sage ihnen ganz einfach hier
sagt sagt sagt das so einfach geht es
muss einfach ganz schnell machen
[Musik]
so jetzt wenn wir den zugang ok eine
prise salz okay
eine prise gut da
[Musik]
so dann haben wir noch vermittelt einen
exakten ja ich musste immer wissen
erwähnen weil der dinge vergisst immer
vieles das ich bin ja schon älter wir
waren übrigens billigwaren muss aber
zählt dass die leute auch mal müssen die
beziehung zwischen zweit wir waren in
der gleichen klasse
da sehen wir wie oft mir sitzen und
genau jetzt einmal ist fakt ist aber die
prob plötzlich und möchtest du musst
sagen das ist schön kluges backpulver
fans sagen nein so dass du doch jetzt
muss der besseres wetter ok also
backpulver ins mehl rein ja das schöne
globus backpulver ins mini nicht mal auf
hirsch langsam anfangen richtig und
damit sich dann steigern ja das war nun
nicht kann feiern
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
mach du mal heißt immer gebacken voraus
180 grad
er heiße so ist das richten
der kleine muck hat seine schuldigkeit
getan niemals schreiben aber nicht viel
und jetzt machen wir erst löffelweise
den rhein bei meiner frau sieht es
immerhin ist ethischer ausgemacht nein
gott sei dank ist das ist eine im mai
backformen gelegt und zwar ist das eine
typische kugel hoch ist er ist geschützt
seit 1923 musst du das ist auf jeden
fall dass mir das allein mit dem sli
2414 schrägstrich 28 rennen springen
zwar ist es nur in kokons hätten das ist
ein kokon schreibt irgendwo ist das
gerät man auch blickt man etwa zwei
drittel des teils in die form mathematik
dreimal die form das auf was du machst
dich schön zwar muss die kamera schauen
derzeit hält schon ausgebaut hat und
eigentlich zu gar gegen kompliziert kann
man doch etwa ein drittel des teils okay
hier drin und 213 daten zusammen macht
ist ein gang kommt cacau
es gibt dann der dunkelheit in marmor
das gerne
das muss man herausfinden wie viel man
also mit dunklem einen teig mark machen
haltung erhebungen mal geschneit
hauptsach kalorien aber nein das war
falsch macao hat keine kalorien das der
fall spielt er zugemacht
wenn du über 70 prozent schokolade zu
nehmen ist haben wir schon nicht okay du
vielleicht schon nicht wahrscheinlich
nicht du bist ja schon so also wie
gesagt dass rund oben immer so exakt
[Musik]
jetzt nehmen sie die gabel und fährst so
und runter und hebst wenn dunkle und
helle weste gemacht und jetzt kommt das
habe ich mir gedacht ja das habe ich mir
gedacht
also wird die gabel fahren in den hellen
teil zum tun denn dunkler tag unter mir
jetzt kommen der 45 bis 50 minuten bei
180° in der oben ok bei 180° 180 grad
genommen
[Musik]
der kuchen ist jetzt fertig wir haben
ihnen auch ungefähr wieder abkühlen das
in der stunde
okay weil damit er nicht so sperrig ist
weil wir das becken ist dann sieht man
ja was passiert ohren raus und wir haben
hier auch zwei kleine tester ist so
schlau wie das erste kinder probieren
wir den kennt nichts passiert dann von
mir auch was tun also
also nochmal so lässt sich in raus und
jetzt kommt doch mal so so sieht es aus
liebe kinder und jetzt nochmals messer
und dann probieren okay aber dann wieder
zurück rüber oder oder schokoglasur
schwung belastung müssten jetzt mal je
nach geschmack okay wir haben jetzt
leider keine zeit mehr und zwar bekomme
ich jetzt gleich besuch aus der türkei
und drei männer
und wenn die männer mich nichts
schlimmes aber ich möchte ich dass ich
in kürze sehen
sonst kommt das blöd immer einfach nur
zucker ok oder gutachten wurde zu jetzt
braucht ihr futter zu fahren und zwar
nehmen wir schweizer zucker okay da
riecht nach einschätzung fast ohne sind
richtig toll aus und es ist dass zucker
das zucker
der kuchen ist nachdem phoenix alten
familienrezept richtig
untrennbar und da kommt zur seite noch
kommt du darfst du hast immer geht's im
gesicht so ist auch noch genau
irgendwie macht ist heller und zwar ist
es da was das was aus besonderen damals
mehr weiß wo er herkommt ist aus was
macht ist ja nein nein nein damals habe
ich sagen damals das damals kommt aus
woher kommt das was ich mache ja richtig
aus damaskus
so ein stück stahl jetzt ab und nochmal
ein stück okay ihr zweites probieren und
das geben wir ins fotostudio und lebt
jetzt weiter für das probieren ok und
sagt wie schmeckt nicht nur alleine
meine freundin auch und man hat für den
papa und probiere mannschaft
[Musik]
schmeckt gut wollt ihr noch mal ein
rezept funktioniert das einzig du dein
leben wahrscheinlich der wahnsinn ist
alles spricht hier so ein debakel
ok auf jeden fall war das rezept
wahnsinnig einfach wirklich ein rezept
von bruni ihr niemals gesagt hast du so
was hinter kommt ich bin wirklich
erschrocken und drückt man täuscht sich
wirklich meistens war ja so ich erwarte
von mir nix und nachher trotzdem
enttäuscht auf jeden fall
vielen dank fürs zuschauen und das
nächste mal wieder bei backen mit ihrem
bildungsniveau
juni beraten macht's gut
und jetzt müsst ihr wieder zurück wir
haben euch hier ausgelegt und bring euch
euren eltern zurück okay okay
hier bleiben bei uns für immer wir
hatten ja also kommen halt trotzdem
angegeben
[Musik]